hello i'm gav welcome to the slo-mo guys
this video
is sponsored by warner brothers to
celebrate the release of tennis
name it and for the trigger
[Music]
yeah shooting the bullet you're catching
it
i'm very excited i've shown up here
today to make a lovely little video
nice clean studio however someone's left
it in quite a state
so i'm not really 100 sure what to do i
feel like i should give christopher
nolan
a cheeky bell oh that's the wrong thing
it's speed dial
yeah all right chris disclaimer no
actual christopher nolan's were called
in the making of this video
i'm talking to myself like a lunatic
how's it going yeah gavin slumber guys
yeah yep yep yep uh i've just shown up
to the studio
to do this turnip video tennis slow-mo
guys collab
someone's trashed the place chris uh
there's paint all up the walls
broken glass some some sort of gauze on
the floor and a little bit on the
ceiling as well
what do you mean i did it i just got
here
it hasn't happened yet inversion from
from ten got it yeah yeah yeah okay so
that's an elephant's toothpaste
use the flask oh okay i see it let's see
the flask all right cheers chris oh
but before you go chris do you reckon i
could get an early screening of tenet
hello okay he's busy bloke he's got
stuff to do
he said use the flask
i feel like this is slightly out of
order but let's give it a go
[Music]
um
well that was by far the best backwards
elephant toothpaste that i've ever seen
this stuff works
very well however it has revealed a load
of glass
and a rock so here's what i think
happened
someone chucked a rock at a window that
was here for no reason
so in theory all i need to do to reform
the window reclaim the glass
is throw the rock
we'll obviously film this at a thousand
frames per second in 4k
here we go
huh oh you know what
i shouldn't be throwing the rock i need
to catch the rock
[Music]
it's a heavy rock
well that worked like a charm and it's
covered in paint
which means it must fit over that weird
gap
i think we're getting good at this
[Music]
oh it's not light why is everything
heavy
okay perfect fit there now for this
bars looking thing if i use all of my
super specialized
forensic ability it looks like the paint
went that way
so i'm going to take this paint covered
back
that was probably the tool of choice and
pop on this paint covered mask
so a lefty swing like this
in reverse but for the run-up i'll need
to start
back here do one of these
that is way faster than a mop i think
i'm done
i think this is it walls are clean this
glass is clean the floor
ah what is that
covered in hair
in theory this will work
ew
that one's white
[Music]
well this place is looking much better
my face however
is not i'm exhausted after all that
although technically
i don't think i am exhausted yet is that
right
not quite sure big thanks to warner
brothers for sponsoring this video
john david washington is the new
protagonist who journeys through a
twilight world
of international espionage on a mission
that will unfold
in something beyond real time not time
travel
inversion get your tickets now and see
tenet
only in theaters thank you very much for
watching make sure you subscribe and
i'll see you next time
all i have for you is a word tell it
tell it you're not shooting the bullet
you're catching it only in theaters
experience it in imax rated pg-13